sospetti ha chiesto celeste blu sta
seguendo si sta seguendo scappando nonno
devo andare in bagno facendo da cucina
ma ci sono vanno il mio cibo è un
cellulare bisogno del nuovo manga sulla
nuova mappa è il simbolo non vinceva mai
metti i capelli come i nuovi
io ricordo da unicorno evitare la
carretta e morigerato ma se io mi piace
se questo vino raggiunge i 20 mila mi
piace fare un altro episodio nella nuova
mappa di among a tanzi scriveteci nei
commenti corte inviate seppure in quali
modalità giocare come potete vedere il
mio personaggio è già celebre s con il
corridoni corridoio di vitale e lo so
prima di giocare con noi eseguiti su
inter roma il nome anida stories fronti
e vitale stiamo giocando assieme per
questa partita e vediamo cosa capiti av
aiuta
[Musica]
e allora già so che sarà difficilissimo
e non avete visto lo scorso episodio in
cui abbiamo reagito a tutti i nuovi
capelli abbiamo dato un voto a 10 tutti
nuovi cappelli skin eccetera abbiamo
reagito alla mappa che abbiamo visto per
la prima volta da vederlo dopo questo
perché super divertente abbiamo anche
giocato un po stile o voglio far
divertente così scoprite anche i nostri
capelli preferiti mappa e norme non
abbiamo ancora provato tutte le nuove
tasse una task divertentissimo che abita
le piacerà molto e di cucinare la cena a
mandare nella stanza delle armi secondo
me anche voi siete super spaesati perché
appunto la mappa è uscita da pochissimo
agli di giorni e quindi probabilmente
anche voi dovete ancora a capire bene
dove sono le stanze dove andare magari
per aloni di vara una prima volta che
state vedendo questa mappa infatti come
puoi vedere perché prima risultato
andando da una parte all'altra tutela
tank una vistosa le pistole dobbiamo
mettere a posto ecco bisogna metterlo a
posto qui penso che ma che bello avere
anche novità
a ognuno al posto suo
ma si possono usare queste contro le
nuove zone oppure da impostori stare ci
rimane solo la task della spazzatura e
basta eh sì perché siamo in tanti a
cucinare qualcosa quelle la cugina e
bellissimo poi qua ci sono dei quadri di
creme il famoso le telecamere dopo che
abbiamo finito le tasche vuoi giocare
tutto il fiamma uguale telecamere perché
ci sono queste nuove telecamere che fin
qui vedi tutte le stanze troppo troppo
belle
ma sbaglio o gli impostori ancora non
hanno eliminato nessuno corto non
abbiamo ancora scoperto punto sap
marrone sasso
crediamo qualche sospetto trascorrendo
il tempo dai votiamo qualcuno secondo me
e marrone secondo me marrone
secondo me il gf dove si trasportiamo
perché un'altra novità e ogni qualcuno
sei un emergency mi ai cassonetti
l'ho fatto ora devo fare un altro non è
più da un dubbio tra l'altro anche la
musica è diversa alla stessa mente sono
sentite questo sottofondo curioso chiuda
aereo godiamo marrone allora sospetti ha
chiesto celeste
[Musica]
a rallentatore perché c'è una matita
gigante di ci sono certe cose che non
capisco che per i discorsi si sta
seguendo si sta seguendo sta scappando
nonno andare in bagno perché continua a
seguirci qui tante oppure non ci ha
eliminato quindi nuovo se non era
imposto uno stage editore tasca stare
con noi lo faremo a rifare completare
lavorata aspetta comunque è molto bella
questa mappa perché c'è un po più di
tempo per esaltarsi per ingegnarsi per
capire un po le cose sembra un po pd
strategia mentre vendola classica mappa
era un po più veloce e rapido il gioco
ultimo vediamo un'altra dobbiamo ancora
provare il favore delle nuove età noi
abbiamo finito abbiamo fatto che non
siamo subito a guardare le camere di
sicurezza eccola sensore siamo ancora
fuori ancione non avevo nessun sospetto
però ha tra l'altro questa cosa e nuova
se puoi cliccare direttamente scrive da
solo la presa la parola sta scadendo il
tempo voglio pubblico nero o rosa erano
il razz
le fettine robot sono cosa tutti morti
no va bene
[Musica]
bellissimo eliminare tutti i giorni 2
notti tutti guarda cosa farà se mi ero
lì dove non genero
ma in un vento
ok ok ci spostiamo donato no no no
pressione uscire che via vai elimina
giallo si chiede rosso io voto rosso no
non è stato trovato cadavere una
riunione d'emergenza era un bambino
siamo un pò store in questa stanza
bellissima vai dai 302 caffè scappa
scappa per un vento per non fare
tuttosport i nomi che non c'e nessuno ci
ha messo tranquillo vai cucina facendo
da cucina stampando il mio cibo primo
preliminare un'ottava sopra abbiamo
fatto qua sotto
dice che è sceso giu proviamo a vedere e
se sì dove saras dove stesse andando
scorso ecco luca ok abbiamo tutti gli
effetti il cuore o il corno da unicorno
bimbisicuramente sono quelli che vi
piace di tutti ma nessuno ha scelto la
cacchetta stimolo che abbiamo con la
semplicità troviamo nuove tac sono super
curiosa di provare tutte sono venuto
foto un forza genoa ho visto gente chi è
chi è colore viola
vediamo se lo aveva eliminato il viola
si vedrà
siete bravissimi vediamo anche questo
stato e speriamo di dare il massimo
voglio provare tutte le tappe muove
allora dobbiamo andare in security ott
a volte qui vicino se non sbaglio ma
parole ce li ha ma anche se voglio
andare lì e bellissimo per la ragione si
sta seguendo gli ok finché siamo in tre
così va bene secondo me perché almeno
nove di si proteggono ipotizziamo sono
tutti qua allora verde scendeva d'acqua
sotto fino a qui ok allora dobbiamo fare
con la regione che tra 12 e 14 di andare
a tutti 6 38 quindi indietro avuto nel
nostro paese visto fare esattamente
quando è 34 07 ok perché no nome l'ho
accettato perché sono tutti qua credo
che non abbiamo data in cui siamo tutti
siamo tutti qua tutti insieme si vestono
la vicenda bravi è la classica tazzina
download delle mappe io volevo scoprire
tutte le nuove tappe è un cellulare che
dobbiamo fare qui e di come sta
ma non c'è connessione provato in alto
deco progress ovvero effetti boccone per
un cellulare fuori
[Musica]
i fatti sono così potete starebbe
arancione no blu bene abbiamo portato
blu perché hanno detto che blu estate
vediamo se lui siria abbia molte hanno
votato
se non prendiamo giocatori sono indotti
nati ed è stato bravissimo
insomma i lavori allora cominciamo dalla
cucina e al mio posto preferito se ce
l'hanno stufa eliminarlo subito
eliminerò soltanto sta andando piano si
che mi hanno chiuso
c'era qualcuno vicino a noi perchè non
ci abbia visto o forse rosso ci ho visto
abbiamo rischiato però non penso che ci
abbia visto hanno votato ben aprono e
pari con però per fortuna non sanno
beccata possiamo spostarci molto più
velocemente nei 20 no no no no è meglio
che non addirittura meglio che non solo
che non siamo sospetti che si potrà
forse il rosso sia allontanato è però
arrivato il bianco è un po rischioso
adesso se c'era la mia molinari magari
trovo un vento mi posso poi allontanare
alla un 29 di c'era già qualcuno a cui
vigilano che ansia
allora proviamo a salire su ma noi ci
sta seguendo vuole proprio essere
eliminato bye bye qualcuno è salito solo
sentito e passano molto bene devo a
prenderlo
vediamo se ci ha votato qualcuno si
brucia solo dato allora la prossima
notte potevo blu colori di mia
adoro questo senza guardarci arrosto qua
c'è il razzo qua eliminiamo è meglio che
scappi 44 non ci vai minare sempre
spetta manca ancora un secondo
sospettato di noi tra l'altro eliminarmi
ma eliminarlo per pagare importi il
corpo dove dove tu preliminare
ecco qui c'è l'attesa sembra meno ne sia
quando si nero ancora non l'ha visto il
corpo le bacche e paura ma siamo qua a
strane osato e stranissima questa stanza
non li stanno trovando questo è un altro
no è sempre miti sempre la stanza delle
emergenze meeting diamo il nostro
ascensore che è comodo averlo messo che
cos'è questo delle notizie ne va be ma
dove siamo
ci siamo persi cosa sono le piccole
stanze ste cose camere da letto
siamo nella mappa è troppo grande non
riescono vent'anni c'è qualcuno passa 8
diamo avete pochetto era qua sotto
sì sono in due sono in due spetta a 7 a
7 e dobbiamo dividere quindi penso che
forse sono gli unici due sopravvissuti
quindi se ne eliminiamo 1 abbiamo vinto
dice forse sono troppo vicini però
aspetta un altro
la rosa ho paura che mi vedono da lì si
interessi perché erano rimasti solo in
due sedute o no però più ferrato longa
no no si è rotto il gioco si vede per
niente bloccato tutto che io sono il
caos dinamo gas funzionando bene non si
riesce a entrare la striscia azione non
è placata truffa io volevo giocare
ancora
proviamo ad aspettarvi dello stesso cede
qualcosa
purtroppo abbiamo provato a ricreare un
altra partita ma non ce la fa a creare
si dà un messaggio di errore che quindi
purtroppo ci dispiace un sacco ma non
possiamo continuare le partite con voi
però stiamo superfortunati super
contenti che siamo riusciti a fare
queste partite assieme a voi le volete
che riproviamo lasciate un bel mi piace
qua sotto e faremo altre partite assieme
a voi magari con modalità diverse
migliaia telefoni commentate vedere lo
scorso video mongatti in cui il re ha
già una novità
cliccate qua per vederlo oppure cliccate
una delle altre castellini cliccate su
quella che preferite